It is Hurricane game day. Kids have got their setup.
They were blissfully unaware of everything going on.
We started getting the outer bands.
So lots of tornadoes and wind and just the gross stuff.
And we have a few Hurricane rules in this house.
Logan, what are the Hurricane rules?
If I use a dish, it has to be cleaned immediately.
No dirty dishes get left in the sink.
What else? Uh,
only eat from fridge and freezer.
Until we lose power. Yes,
cause we wanna empty that out as much as possible.
Do not grab a snack from the pantry.
I know it's go to, but absolutely not.
And last one AC said that 62.
Don't open the doors. And if you're cold,
get a flipping blanket. Bingo.